pour Michael Chang et sa famille visé
par l'intimidation de Pékin l'ingérence
étrangère prend une tournure personnelle
il accepte le signe de réconfort de la
ministre mais les deux sont rapidement
passés de la sympathie à la
confrontation
identifiez comme responsable de la
campagne d'intimidation contre lui n'a
pas encore été expulsé du Canada
l'ambassadeur chinois a été convoqué en
signe de réprimande dévoile la ministre
afin d'exprimer notre irritation face à
ses actions intolérables et
répréhensibles
chinois en guise de représailles mais
elle n'est pas prête à prendre cette
décision maintenant ni à répondre aux
questions des journalistes
la charge des parties d'opposition s'est
poursuivi à la période des questions
[Applaudissements]
le président de la chambre
deux conservateurs qui accusent le
gouvernement de mentir ont été expulsés
partisane les flèches étaient surtout
dirigées vers le diplomate chinois le
Premier ministre va-t-il expulsé ce
diplomate qu'on voit rapidement expulser
cette individu là il ne doit pas être
ici dans le pays s'il menace les députés
expulsera expulsera pas la ministre
jolie dit vouloir prendre une décision
rapide mais réfléchie elle veut d'abord
évaluer les possibles représailles que
pourrait prendre Pékin et qui pourrait
avoir des conséquences fâcheuses sur les
Canadiens qui sont en Chine ici
Christian Noël Radio-Canada Ottawa